not so good afternoon today Victor will
present as a Brownback seminar or we
will change the name soon into
Tupperware seminars or something like
that so welcome and thanks for being
here Victor has a Bachelor of law and
master's degree in marketing and
communications with postgraduate studies
studies in local economic development I
think it was part of how do we diversify
certain profiles in intimate and in the
program and in that sense you were
looking for experience in public private
partnerships agriculture marketing
agribusiness and sustainable development
say it has Victor sorry has lived in
Asia Europe and America where he worked
for the FAO dealing with farming market
linkages as well as agricultural market
services in Mexico Victor was with the
internet inter-american Development Bank
prior prior to joining similar here in
CIMMYT he has worked on public-private
partnerships within the SIP program
he is component leader for masa grow
product or and has been working in
different projects in the let in the
systemic densification strategy on
farmer market linkages and will present
first today farmer market linkages in
the context of sustainable
intensification systems and before we
start thanks for Victor for doing the
effort taking the time like everybody
else who's presenting the Brownback's to
put your work out there to be looked at
mix I yes so thank you Ron for your
presentation thanks everyone for taking
the time to be here I wanted to give you
a little bit of an overview of what we
have been doing in terms of fundamental
market linkages and how does this fit
into existing efforts and program of
sustainable intensification strategy so
the presentation is going to start
framing a little bit the scope of the
activities we are doing and then we will
see some mix
pose in actual projects so we like to
define ourselves as providing input in
this in this sense by providing
strategic interventions through the
value networks of may suite and
associated crops it's perhaps
interesting to highlight here associated
crops because it's part of CIMMYT
mission to work with with crops
different from maize and wheat but
especially it's important in terms of of
markets aiming at strengthening
commercial relationships based on
sustainability innovation and
competitiveness so what we have been
doing was revealing in which sense we
could provide some added value to what
already was going on on the market and
how we could kind of round the
activities that submit' was already
doing and what we were already doing in
projects dealing with sustainable
intensification being masago
the federal project one of the main
efforts here you can see one of the
infograph is one of the graphics that we
are doing in which we kind of map the
value chain it's interesting to mention
also that we refer here value networks
we want to refer that there are several
readings on value chain and value
networks what is the difference so we
don't think they are those are
incompatible terms we think those need
to be combined so in for instance in the
finance the use of value networks have
been used have been used for years where
they when they refer to the single
actors in a given activity considering
the different role they may have so kind
of the same thing has been adopted by
the university of chopping go we have
been working with Roberto random of
system by understanding how can we do
this I see this as a reading as body
chain could be kind of a 2d projection
of what is going on and a value networks
can be kind of a 3d projection or kind
of isolating a specific player and
understand which are the different
this player plays being a client being a
supplier being a complementary on being
a competitor so we have been mapping the
Mason with value chains with this
perspective also this is an example of
commercial network mapping exercises
that we did with Roberta rendang
in Oaxaca in Chiapas in four states in
2016 we plan to keep working on next
year's in this effort what we do is to
understand how the players relate to
each other in a specific geographical
context we kind of take a picture of
what is going on from a commercial point
of view we take the picture again after
an intervention and understand whether
new links have been produced so that
there are there are some factors that we
cannot understand by reading a simple
value chain but by having this kind of
associations and relationships mapped we
get a better understanding and we
actually want our collaborators
providing support to farmers to also
adopt this commercial networking mapping
methodology so why did we start doing
this kind of work it was mostly because
of the demand of the farmers so misawa's
you know started operating in 2011 soon
after that kind of a couple of years
afterwards we realized that we needed to
develop or to put together a component
that would help farmers to push
correctly their product so we were kind
of helping them to increase their
productivity to increase their
production but some of them were not
linked to markets or were linked
occasionally to markets or not
understanding market dynamics
appropriately and we understood that by
by helping them to understand that we
could help them a lot so we we
systematize the lessons learned like
globally there was some song work of
scimitar already in different projects
and regions in farmer market linkages or
in agricultural marketing or value chain
reading and we incorporated that into
the operation of massage
and of course we we went through
extensive literature review to see what
was what hat being developed how could
we contribute to that this is an example
of an in front of you found early
product that we developed saying what
what is the kind of route that a farmer
should take by feeling that is not
competing with his peer farmers or the P
farmers they can organize themselves
they can do joint efforts together these
are some examples of materials that we
have been reading so as bran was
mentioning I was working at the
marketing team at FAO and we recover
part of that work and we Scheffer
outside the David Camm who were kind of
who have been writing of this topic for
years these are some examples of
projects or forming of the
inter-american Development Bank and of
course and of course this the socio
economics program of CIMMYT has
developed also some quite interesting
documents that we have been utilizing
these are some other examples this is
one of the last actually one of the last
products with Andre Duvall Jason Donovan
working on an identification of
experiences in the sea here but also
outside of the CER and understanding how
the so called VCD value chain for
development could be better increase so
starting from all this literature we we
intend to bring it back to what is going
on right
so we developed several guidelines
practical guidelines for farmers for
operators to incorporate value chain
development concepts in the in the
project so for us to for us to start or
to work on a specific region we need
different elements to combine so in we
need innovative farmers we need an
enabling environment and we need willing
buyers so the farmers and innovative
when they adopt sustainable
intensification sustainable agriculture
when they kind of do this transition
from traditional methods to innovation
which is what we are helping them to do
with projects such as massage
then we provide capacity development in
agricultural marketing strategies and we
we understand that promoting farming
organization is also key for this
innovative farmers to succeed then we
need an enabling environment so for that
to happen we need a public pull up
policies that support the whole process
and we go with public policies policies
at a multi level so not only at federal
or national level but also at a regional
level another important factor is kind
of identifying and highlighting the
existing synergies amongst the different
projects that might be conquering and
the same in the same region and that is
something that has been challenging but
we have been working through the
different projects that are for instance
taking place in Mexico and then the fact
of institutional networks strengthening
a linkages that means that we link with
already in place he force in terms of
trading marketing and farming
organizations and we provide support to
those existing structures then we need
willing buyers so we stimulate new
business models we will see what we
understand for new business models in a
minute and also we look for buyers that
are interested in the tribal dimension
of sustainability meaning
environmentally social and economic
sustainability of course so what do we
understand by new business models are
those who include the stimulation of new
services or goods associated with
sustainable intensification
interventions for instance the
development of appropriate mechanization
services or the development of
manufacturers of post-harvest tools as
well as generating extra added value to
existing processes and players this is a
drawing that you have seen thousand
times maybe so it is the model of the is
the infrastructure of
innovation hub so this is a model along
with we have been working for for some
years now so the the research platform
is where is-where farm is where
researchers do hypothesis and we bring
the market related hypothesis also to
this exercise so by using and validating
varieties demanded by the industry into
the research plots and also promoting
market oriented crop rotation which also
meets our combines or adds to agronomic
crop rotation then we go to the modules
or to farmers that adopt those
technologies and we focus on income
efficiency and contract farming as a
couple of areas of work with these
farmers those farmers kind of serve as a
model for others to adopt the
technologies and then we have the impact
areas where we promote farmer
organizations and a better value chain
integration so both are the spected
results in farmer market linkages
interventions these are some of them may
be strengthened overall competitiveness
amazing with production systems from
farm to the final product so
understanding well seeing it can add a
meaningful value to producers but also
to other players in the value chain
farmers abilities recognize developed
and enhanced and also training is part
of the core business of SEMA to say so
we kind of tune up to two specific
training on market business models based
on the tripod dimension of
sustainability promoted tools and
methodologies to strengthen inclusive
market approach developed and spread and
develop foster among all value network
actors it's important to mention that
several players from the private sector
but also from the public sector have
seen value in symmetry in a neutral
facilitator of processes and this is
something that we have been doing with
inter-institutional working groups and
some other spaces for common discussion
so when when we decided when we are
invited to provide input to a specific
project or a specific need we start with
that with a diagnosis so we understand
what's going on why we are required why
what is the problem that we try to
tackle right so we do of course
literature review specific for that
region to understand what what has been
what have been experiences that we can
learn from then we do a collection of
primary information through sourcing
methods such as value chain mapping and
market research and do further
understanding of market needs by
understanding who would be the buyer or
who would be the the pool force in that
intervention that we want to promote
then we design a customized intervention
based on the existing model and what the
project might require and we do start
with the implementation of the project
and a constant evaluation or feedback
loop so this is an iterative process
where we incorporate information on
communication technologies or mill
indicators monitoring evaluation
accountability and learning indications
and learning unsustainability indicators
that will bring into the formula then we
scale out and actually is not the idea
they seem it does the whole process
especially not the last step of scaling
out the ideas that we prove methodology
or that we prove an intervention to be
worthy then the industry and the
different players in the industry would
have to play their role in validating
that father and making them making it
growth an important area as I was
mentioning at the beginning is providing
appropriate training so we developed
several courses marked market related
courses or training not about they have
been implemented yet some of them are on
the second year some others are still to
be developed as you can see this right
program so the ideas
we'll be contract farming management of
rural business farmer organizations and
inclusive business models and we have
several trainings with different as
resisted each of them each of those that
we are pushing in our agenda and that is
also the importance to provide
sufficient and useful materials for
training offered the dissemination of
information or debut that we have so one
of the things that we think it's missing
in a lot of cases in Mexico is is
contrary culture and we had velop an
explainer video explaining why it's a
good idea maybe to organize and to and
to understand what as the other benefits
of contract agriculture being whoever it
is who provides that contracting lastly
for this session for this start of the
presentation I wanted to explain that we
are developing farmer market linkages
specific indicators to strengthen the
indicator matrix of the projects that we
are working on so in the area of
productivity we are studying as results
indicators yield profit available grain
to trade an adoption of contract farming
as some significant indicators and we
are discussing also with donors what our
impact indicators that are useful for
them such as ill evolution profit
evolution or market effective
participation index which is actually a
recent indicator that we are developing
these days so now how do we how do we go
from all of these theory or from this
ideas to practice or to implementation
these are the ongoing projects in which
there is a component of farmer market
linkages all of them are in Mexico at
the moment all of them are in Mexico of
course part of our lab for proving
practices
was the massacre of the federal project
then we got Massaro Vanuatu well we
could do some more in-depth specific
research for instance in the case of
alternative crops for Vanuatu and then
we got several projects with main
industry players such as Kalos Nestle or
guru per window which have started quite
recently within the last 12 months and
we have also a project in its second
year now in the Finnish Rally Yucatan
with funda theologian as al mundo Maya
we will see a few examples of work going
on on these projects so what kind of
activities how do we phrase our
interventions in those projects here
there are some of them the idea is to
provide value in in doing value mapping
exercises that are relevant at the hub
level at the regional level and we also
feel that are in a good position to link
the work that is very being carried out
in terms of agronomy in terms of
Technology Development and in terms of
of markets so these are some of the
areas I don't want to to read them in
detail but you can see them here
these are instead some typical type
ologies where we have been working for
the last couple of years so animal feed
sector nixtamalization industry a
growing industries or the retail LED
interventions or niche markets in each
of these areas there are different goals
depending on who is the attractor or who
is promoting the intervention and we are
working with different products so for
instance the animal feed sector white
mace is not required but triticale or
barley are incorporated as interesting
associated crops in the next
immunization industry of course is
focused on white mace niche markets
deals with landrace maize so we have a
kind of a variety of of areas to
intervene and as part of our exercise to
review what was going on and on in terms
of methodology we
we start we identify that link
methodology who was which was jointly
developed by the sea at in Colombia and
if pre was a methodology that could be
useful for grains and that had not been
used for the grains so we brought some
people from from SIA to help us
incorporate that and this methodology
what does is kind of assessing inclusive
and sustainable business models and in
ethology that starts that has four main
tools one is the value chain map which
means ok I understand what where I am
working who are the actors what roles
are they playing then I design or I
understand what is the business model
with a business model campus to which is
a classic pool in which we understand
how different actors being there being
the producer being the aggregator or
being the end-user how do they see
themselves what kind of business to the
thing they have or they play in the
chain then we do the new business model
principle which is a tool to evaluate
how inclusive trading relationship is
and what can be modified in there and
then we go to the fourth tool which is
the prototype cycle or actually
implementing those modifications into
the business model of the of the
organization that we think can help out
and that is also guided by the same
participants there is a feedback loop we
keep working on this prototype or cycle
until we understand that business
relationship between two players is
actually optimized what this interesting
is to is to is to highlight that we have
been quickly transitioning from the
reading of the let's say theory
materials to the implementation of those
in field so in for in front of the
certain projects that I mentioned before
in 2007 we in 2016 and 2017 we have been
training let's say project partners to
implement link in their in the regions
as
we have some some examples here in
Massaro we have got like six cases of
partners that are being using League
have been using linked masada wanna hot
as well in the Kellogg's project as well
and in the mill packet on project as
well so as you can see some of this work
is done with native language made some
other is done with more typical or
hybrid products certified products etc
so we have different different scenarios
and different market topologies that we
have been mapping and this is the
numbers one two three four refer to
those numbers and the stage to which we
have reached to date in those
collaborations here we have some
pictures from the field from our
partners from these organizations in
Mexico that are conducting this value
chain mapping and following exercises
this is exercise one value chain mapping
this is exercise to well you do the
model the business model canvas and it's
interesting to see that they have been
quite happy and finding useful this this
methodology this is actually inputs that
have been sent to us during the last
month from from these associated
organizations so here we can see the
body chain map of the north of La Scala
and we can see here kind of the hwacha
rate data we can have with this
exercises so this is these are specific
commercial data gathering from the
Fronteras caliber we have the different
buyers that have been identified what is
the buying price that they pay for the
product what is the kind of payment
method that they utilize what is the
demand the estimated total demand that
the buyer can have and some quality
requirements so as you can understand
this is very useful information for for
for farmers to know and for farm
advisors to contribute to in fact
Atticus estate we did
case of comparing ving and sunflower
work we actually validated that by using
some flower in the innovation plot and
being in the control plot which is a
typical product in in that region we
could see that maybe the benefit cost
ratio of using sunflower could be
actually better so we were a company in
some producers to move from being to
some flower and to understand also what
was the estimate demand for for
sunflower as a sum as an example of of
the desert some pictures of workshops
that we conducted in in 2016 and we
reached about two thousand six hundred
forty producers and other players in
this eruption were access to farmer
market linkages component some other
cases that I wanted to to share with you
is the project in Yucatan is in this
project we have a component to promote
Landry's land resumes in niche markets
so some of the activities that we have
been doing leading to that objective is
participatory workshop with farmers to
review the projects commercialization
strategy so as link suggests we don't
arrive to a community and say this is
what you need to do rather we go there
we work with farmers we understand
through participatory workshops what
they want to do if they want to actually
trade with their products if they feel
comfortable comfortable with the way
they are managing their selling and so
on then we work on a catalog to promote
landrace maize which has been kind of
it's being a complex exercise because we
need to carefully assess what is the
available volume that can be traded
especially in communities that have not
been trading before so this is part of
the of the exercises that we are doing
we review and provide
to the donor and to other interested
parties key considerations in terms of
pricing and logistics and the last
activity that we are doing is actually a
tasting workshop where metallic Palacios
is helping to to plan which is scheduled
for for next January where we will have
chef and consumers characterizing
organoleptic characteristics of this of
three selected maize varieties that have
maybe a volume higher than others in the
in the peninsula Yucatan and that can be
traded and appreciated by chefs and the
consumers this this slide shows part of
the variables that we have been reading
in the field that we have been observing
in the field and that we include into
our recommendations to to the players so
for instance in the case of Landry's
maize producing in parallel Yucatan it
it of course belongs to the milpa Sibley
mill persistence or milpa system is
highly conditioned by weather and by
seasonal area of milk by itself then in
terms of prices we have observed in
local markets that price buys from 5 to
12 pesos a kilo there are also
opportunities to add extra value to
product for instance premium quality or
certification to date there is no extra
value to to to the to the product itself
so we think there is an opportunity
there to increase so how the price that
the farmers would receive and also it's
very important that we are always
highlighting this part in order to avoid
local market distortions we need further
understanding or detail understanding of
local market dynamics to establish
maximum buying prices so high prices
might differ existing equilibrium in
terms of cell consumption or internal
trade within the community those are
the variables our under affection that
we have been seeing how the price shapes
in a specific local market so this take
up this takes us to or to the whole
other range of products or projects that
we are developing so lately we have been
writing and implementing projects on
responsible sourcing as you can as you
have seen this is kind of um kind of a
purpose that can be applied to most of
them kind of the the objective that we
want to to pursue so to build and to con
and to consolidate a commercial is sound
responsible sourcing model aligned with
the vision procedures and requirement of
the other industry promoting the
development of business relationships
based on trust stability and reciprocal
profit generation and allowing companies
to meet the local mace and we demand as
we have been seen and as we have been
discussing for the last years
if CIMMYT has now this this vision this
wider vision on interventions in the
value chain and we have seen that
several companies have an interest in
shifting from import to establishing
long term relationships with local
producers of of major wit so that's kind
of the word that we are doing with as I
was saying before callousness lay or
bimbo so we kind of combine the pool and
the push mechanism to create an enabling
environment for responsible sourcing
projects to thrive those are at the at
the left we have some some activities
that we that we do in terms of pool or
push as you can see value chain mapping
and analysis support to private sector
in building a reliable local procurement
capacity development the the support on
sustainable intensification with
technologies and agronomy that we do in
every project market oriented production
and of course another value that we are
shaping is traceability and
sustainability indicators all the way
from farm
- to the company so here we have some
drawings on what kind of interventions
do we do we do and how do we explain it
so for instance this is the case of
Nestle and as Nev wants to increase the
radio of
local procurement of maize in the state
of Vanuatu which is which is actually
quite low now and depends on a couple of
intermediaries and this is kind of the
way we saw it so we see okay there is
this company that has a high volume
demand there are farmers everywhere in
the state most of them are disconnected
some received technical assistance but
it's just occasionally and there are not
enough there is not maybe enough
infrastructure in the region in terms of
storage or logistics so there are some
problems that we have identified so how
can we solve these problems well in
terms of reaching we can help
identifying farmers and help them - or
convince them to create organizations so
this SP Aristotle provision rule also is
family organizations getting together so
technical assistance is provided by the
project or by align projects in this
case the government of Guanajuato is
paying massive eluana hot is funding
masala Vanuatu and that helps of course
to other players that want to to buy
maize in the rhythm major wheat actually
in the case of Nestle is maize and wheat
then we have a component component of
work with the communities and that was
for the specific request of the donor so
we are promoting bio 45 major qpm in
some self-consumption
areas or smaller farmers in the state of
Vanuatu we developed sustainability
indicators together with the company and
we we are making sure with our
monitoring evaluation system that those
indicators are being captured then we
also work with a number of partners but
also
Financial Partners to make sure that
there is the in that to make sure that
the infrastructure needed for this
project to to work is built is in place
and well this is kind of the drawing of
the intervention and we also understand
that there are several kind of producers
in this in this scenario and that in
parallel we are going to work with these
three kind of group of producers and we
are actually helping them to transition
from one category to other category so
here for instance category C would be
the producers who are not linked to
markets and that are living like far
from the I don't know from the company
reach out so we work with them to make
them visible the importance of working
together of forming organizations
increasing the quality the majority of
their product so hopefully these
producers would transition into two B
which are farmers who are already
organized but they are not added adding
extra value they are selling their
products to maybe a copy of others to
those who are storage and then sell to
the company so maybe if these
organizations could do the the wrong
storage could add some value or could
help could get a better price for the
service they provide and we have the
aggregate Orozco Murphy analyst who are
those who typically have been working
with with the company so Nestle or other
companies of course rely in big
aggregators but the percentage of grain
that they obtain from these aggregators
is going to reduce as a percentage as
other farmers become suppliers as well
of the company this is an example of
work instead with with Kellogg's what we
have been identifying what was what were
the main bottlenecks between the company
are the main and the main aggregator
that they
deal with so whoever is familiar with
link methodology and we will understand
that this is one of the tools that we
utilize which is a scorecard analysis
well we see the perception of how good
how healthy is the relationship and the
mutual understanding between the company
and the main aggregator and going we see
that there is a difference in in reading
or understanding of the position then we
kind of try to solve this this
difference then we do a value chain we
have done a value chain risk matrix
understanding what were the main factors
that could offer that could affect the
sustainability of the of the company
business and we provided this kind of
exercises which is not Chinese but
almost but the company has the code I
couldn't I didn't want to put here
exactly go to where the recommendations
because this is of course confidential
information but we identified different
kind of risks we identified possible
mitigation strategies and suggested
route of action this is also an example
of a value chain map that we conducted
for for for this last project and well
this take this takes me to the last
slide which is what is coming
we have been quite I would say quite
dynamic during the last few months in
incorporating new topics we would like
to see what is the what what are the
opportunities to include public
procurement responsible public
procurement into the grain sector so
there are some projects in Brazil and
also in the European Union of
governments buying grain for I don't
know it can be for it for the jail for
the pigeon system for the schools and so
this public expenditure in food is been
reoriented to more to incorporate some
sustainable indicators or or awareness
kind of awareness another area of work
is using the information communication
tools for for weather trust ability and
transparency
it is interesting to notice that IBM or
Walmart have been doing have been
working with blockchain technology to
incorporate those elements of high-end
technology into the food sector and we
think that seemeth could also play a
role there we are working on
understanding what could we actually our
fit the organization such as the
sustainable agriculture initiative or
ICL Alliance which actually support
companies in developing sustainability
standards and we are in contact with
this with these organizations to
understand what is coming next in terms
of sustainability indicators so that we
can be ready to provide that kind of
information to the companies or to
whoever we are working with in projects
and another element that we would like
to incorporate that within next year may
be is participatory guarantee systems or
participatory certification also known
as participatory participatory
certification as close to zero cost
option for farmers to certify the
product which we think is something that
there are several cases of of success
particularly in Asia now Mexico is kind
of starting to explore this self
certification scheme within something
what we can contribute to and that was
surrounded i hopes you
[Applause]
if you have questions now we have some
minutes and I'm happy to respond Thank
You Victor for the presentation I think
you showed a lot of tools which is
always nice I think showing really how
to do it
of course my question is about scaling
because the word even popped up may when
you can go to I think it's the fifth
slide or so you had this flow chart and
then at the end it was like and now we
need to scale out yeah that one so my
question is now you say we focus very
much on the design its implementation
and then the next step would be scale
out right so I think I assume that in
the first two blocks you reach maybe
hundreds of thousands of beneficiary
basically and the next you want to go to
millions right so I think you would
agree that this is maybe more complex
then then what we're actually doing now
so question is what how do you see the
role in in supporting that scaling out
process and and B we should take the
leadership on that block then if we are
not going to do it well I think it
scaling out has to go through different
steps or through different phases and to
the last station we are probably not
going to be the lead of that reaching
millions but we can do some we can do
some interventions in a way to make sure
that a process is validated and it works
out so for instance it wouldn't be
enough if we assume it start
implementing the link methodology and
think look this is something which is
working out but we don't help others to
do that and we don't count on others
opinion to do that so as a first step
into this scaling out exercise is to
work with different partners who are
private small companies providing
services to aggregate to farmers in
Mexico that have been trained and are
using themselves this methodology and
seeing if there is any value in that so
if they understand they understand that
that's useful they will do their own
business by by providing that service
and that's a first step to scale out
then the same thing similarly it works
with the companies so the companies when
they see that a pilot is working out
successfully for them for instance in
the case of bimbo it's very clear that
what they want to do is a pilot because
they want to focus on I don't know it's
not even ten percent of their total
procurement but the idea is to scale
their is to scale it out to other
regions to other countries to other
crops or maybe in the case of mix of
meme or not to other crops but maybe in
the case of Kellogg's they have more
different ingredients they would do that
in other ingredients so we just kind of
put the seed in there and see if we can
support to the scale out process but
it's a complex it's a complex topic of
their I think they're working on that
could you tell us more about the
indicators of sustainable farming and
whether those can all get into climate
change amelioration or any of those
aspects there are indicators in most of
our projects we have indicators of
knowledge of environmental environmental
area enough production or productivity
so in terms of farmer market linkages we
are more focusing on those having to
deal with productivity aside refer
briefly there are several organizations
working on sustainability indicators for
the agricultural sector so we discuss
with specific d'Honneur in each case
what kind of indicators are you
interested in some of them most of the
indicators that the company are
interested in belong to the matter
mental part or to the income part so I
want my farmers to be more successful in
terms of return of investment or I want
my farmers to have a better management
of the water so some of them are managed
by our colleagues of the ergonomics and
some others are go cows walk out by by
ourselves so these are the ones that we
are kind of monitoring more closely
controlling so we understand that is not
only about producing more battery but
about being more competitive in the way
you produce and by indicating and by
monitoring that over the years we
understand that as a farmer has been
successfully incorporating more more
profit into the into its business there
is this this last indicator I was
referring before market effective
participation index refers to to what
extent a farm at is aware of the
existence of different markets and how
he or she plan strategically his
production towards meeting market
demands so that's an indicator that
after a number of years we understand
how that farmer has transition
and that is valuable for us to
understand whether it had make sense our
intervention or not still is an area
under the constant development and
review but I hope this addresses a bit
your question yes
all right soon
our job is international agricultural
research so we should also be interested
in ensuring comparability across
countries regions and so on so these
indicators you know it would help if we
can ensure some kind of comparability
with say what we're doing in South Asia
so number one would be water use
efficiency - nutrient use efficiency
from a and three emissions and are they
covered or not well what we're doing BOM
do you want to yeah just an example
there is the table of indicators which
includes most ability greenhouse gases
and it's a whole full table that has
been developed it is an extract which is
also fed into the discussions with
monitoring and if meta monitoring and
evaluation and learning unit that is
also working across with the CGI art so
what conclude it's not that this is just
a selection so it may be a bit
misleading by putting the exact I think
this is an example of a specific
specific project where it is important
to highlight is indeed not all projects
are measuring all the indicators maybe
the next step of discussion is what are
the minimal indicators that we agree
across regions that you should measure
being part of those discussions it
becomes very interesting because usually
we step out of the meeting saying every
time should be the minimum indicators
you should measure because depending the
socio economics is that this is this
etcetera on the other hand there is
obviously also the dimension of the
donors so I mean USAID is looking at
indicators a lot of us looking at
indicators who is doing everything from
Mexico so I'm not sure I mean I don't
have the answer where that ends up in
the end but somewhere
a lot of methodological challenges also
to have indicators that are robust
across geographies one aspects of
indicators especially for that type of
work are social indicators equity equity
insistence with responsible sourcing for
example it's a very interesting question
so it's cement but not on instrument we
are quite a few be interested in getting
methods and metrics for those indicators
and I think it's quite a bit more
investment yeah I mean I totally agree
I've been discussing with with brandies
for for some time already and the idea
is that we find you first what are valid
methodologies and useful indicators for
both the beneficiaries that we are
working with and for what the industry
may demand and then how do we streamline
those indicators within the project
portfolio of the program and beyond of
all the different regions I think it's
interesting to look I am drea who's
who's on maternity leave has been
working on that and may be interesting
to ask her to give a presentation but
also for me just to add it has been
quite interesting that on methodology
that cetera is completely different if
you from from the business perspective
because they want those data streams to
go in business continuity which needs to
be
auditable by PwC's and those companies
that they need to be trans able to
translate that into financial indicators
for them because then their insurance
goes that I mean that's a whole even a
whole different dimension where that we
may not be thinking of but if we don't
do that we cannot connect it and then
the pool goes away of what is driving
this because in the end the company is
creating a pool for that so it's even
more it's making it just a little bit
more and another factor that is
important is that time it is the time
that it requires to capture the
indicators analyze and kind of present
them so the industry is pressing has to
have quicker response ratio than we had
previously with institutional donors
which would be okay with us releasing
data of 2 years old and saying ok this
is the indicator of production of the
state of Oaxaca 2014 that you are
delivering that in 16 so
now the companies are telling us okay I
want some system where I can see if not
in real time at least with a delay of
maximum amonth who are our beneficiaries
how are they performing in the field and
so is something that we are actually
trying to tackle with with with the BEM
Bittaker electronic and some other tools
that Andrea and others are working on
and again I mean you mentioned the
cost-benefit of indicators you know I
mean you can have indicators that
interest many people but they are very
difficult and very costly to to update
the upscaling of indicators as well you
know can measure things at the field
level for few farmers but are you scale
that you know when you start working and
and environment and I think all those
issues of interest I think foresee bit
because more and more also donors are
asking for those indicators as a metric
of success
well greenhouse gas emissions is the
typical case where I think we should
kind of work closely with c-cups and
others to understand what is going to be
our methodology a question because I
think that was an interesting comment
how do we how do we avoid or at least
the signals there that by the
interventions instead that we are making
sure that we enter at a level playing
field because one of the element is you
could say I take the farmers and I put
them in contact with the company but
that is not a level playing field
because the companies for really much
way more experienced with negotiating to
farmers which for them are are our
suppliers and that's what they do they
negotiate their supply chain so can you
comment some of the tools and elements
that are being thought of to avoid
falling in that trap and actually
creating disparity rather than
opportunities and a pool for so one
thing that we need to clarify every time
is that we are not traders so that we
cannot make sure that by linking farmers
to companies we our business is going to
happen by itself so what we what we see
is that we want to on one hand empower
farmers to understand what is the value
of the product they have what are the
different markets they can go to and got
are the benefits of working together or
by developing a formal contract farming
or by developing kind of loyalty to the
to the potential companies that are
interested in their products so that's
that's a whole set of work and from the
other side we work with the companies to
kind of transmit they need to understand
the characteristics of the farmers of
the specific region where they want to
source from they of course know the
people but they don't they might not
know how they would react to changes in
the environment such as changing price
scenario or changing weather scenario so
this kind of of of awareness is
important for the companies to have and
also we have the companies to understand
what are the benefits of promoting local
procurement instead of imports in terms
of marketing of image for for the
companies and that they are seeing value
in that so they are kind of open now to
consider buying local
Turing who sure that we know that Mexico
is divided into mono cropping Jones no
we have the areas about the area and so
on so we want to as a part of
sustainable intensification we want
diversification as one of the component
on the other side the contract farming
is more towards specific quality trade
commodity and mono cropping suits
contract farming and vice versa how you
see diversification and market linkage
contract farming should we use only if
useful so that means that not all the
companies and not all farmer groups are
seeing value in contract farming because
contract farming is limited by
stipulated programs
so in that case Mexican xalapa has a
circa and a circa has a service of
contract agriculture which proved to be
useful and unpopular in some regions and
not in others so to start with this with
this thing for us contract farming is
not an obligation then in terms of what
products we do we suggest in crop
rotation we also we always start from
understanding economics so whenever we
see that there are several options in
terms of agronomy appropriate rotation
we see out of those who is the one what
is the one that makes more sense from a
market perspective but not the other way
around we don't see we don't say ok in
Bahia there is a new factory of oil of
papas fritas and then we need to to get
oil from this kind of legume enosis so
we just understand in the system which
is needed which is kind of helping to
nurture soils and then out of that we we
provide some recommendation
I have a question especially you are
talking a lot about market and
specifically about big markets and slay
people
what about small-scale farmers if we see
them yes of course
also as producers and as consumers of
their own cereals as maize and then if
we try to connect them with you say
chefs or these high like level
restaurants how do we ensure that we
that they can still have their own
volume for self consumption and they if
did we give them a nice price and all
these contracts yeah of course it's
gonna be a really nice incentive to sell
everything on most of it and then what
are they gonna eat if they prefer to eat
their own mace perhaps we are going to
make a different type of impact yeah
well I think that was that was pointed
out by I mean we do that by carefully
assessing case by case first we cannot
say that large farmers supply only large
companies so that is the large companies
also supply from small and medium
farmers that get organized that's what
we are doing in Bahia that's where we
are doing in in some in Sinaloa not so
much but in estado de mexico yes we're
doing that for those niche market pool
for that niche market pool that they
want maybe some very specific products
land resumes we have been doing this
exercise community by community in
Venezuela Yucatan to understand what is
the percentage of product that they
consume what is the percentage of
product that they trade in their
communities so we don't affect that we
help them to increase their production
and with that surplus of production we
start talking about selling that so the
volumes are incredibly low for the first
year then we want to help them to make
to see okay maybe they have three actors
of land in average they are planting
less than an actor because it's what
they need but maybe next year they will
think okay I'm gonna duplicate my
production because I know I will have
who someone who's going to buy from from
me so volume setting and price setting
is key and it's something that we work
on in every specific community this is
very time demanding so what we would
want to do is that we have the private
sector I mean small companies farm
advisors dispatcher salary colas that
provide a service to farmers
okay thank you very much shake
[Applause]